my name is [ __ ] Caroline PE I'm 18
years of age a child climate ambassador
a news reporter hello hello today were
looking at deforestation in relation to
I live in a banana in Lusaka Zambia
listening to 99 I really love radio
Radio has become a part of me and I want
a world where each and every person is
fully informed they should have the most
of adequate information in their
fingertips I realized that I was
affected by climate change in 2015 when
Zambia experienced erratic water supply
and narrative electricity supplied where
I come from they depend on electricity
for them to jog water I had to wake up
0-5 every day just to go fetch water
because if I go at 3 or 6 hours I would
find that the water is not there like
everyone would have rushed for it so
climate change for me became personal
because I realized that I wasn't the
only one facing such kind of a situation
the whole Zambia was actually affected
one of the major environmental problems
that we're facing in Zambia is that of M
lists destruction of forests
in Zambia we're losing about 300,000
acres of forest that is cut em lessly
and through the works of Beatrice she
gets an opportunity to go in the
community interview marketeers interview
constructors on the state of the
environment in Lusaka
when I pick up that record that it's
always a challenge and it's always
inspiring and motivating because I know
that whoever I'm going to interview out
there it's either they have the
information or they don't have the
information I as the news report is
going to use the tools that I have you
know the tools that are available which
is radio right now I'm in Kalama
compound it's one of the compounds in
Lusaka the Arab describes that the
demand for choco has really gone high
due to the erratic electricity supply
it's really bad but I hope that people's
mindsets can actually change
[Music]
we're a campaign where we intend to
plant two thousand trees and this
company is called greening the gray so
we're trying to make sure that the gray
that is left as a result of mass
destruction of forest is replaced by
green indigenous trees that are going to
help with different environmental
benefits when I listen to beaches on
radio I feel inspired and she's doing a
lot of things that can benefit our
country and bring out the very best of
every young girl in our country I'm so
very proud of Beatrice because she
someone has now become this
inspirational figure in our community
and many young people really wants to be
like her
[Music]
[Music]